i'm not allowed to say this
i think i'm allowed to say this uh i've
eaten shrooms a couple times
but i haven't gone the full i'm talking
to a few researchers and psychedelics
it's an interesting scientifically place
like what is the portal
you're entering when you take
psychedelics or another would ask is
like
dreams whatever so let me tell you what
i think which is based on
nothing like this is based on my life
right so i don't
your intuition it's based on my it's
based on my
i'm guessing now um based on what i do
know
i would say but i think that well think
about what happens
so you're running your brain's running
this internal model right and it's all
outside of your awareness for really
you see the you feel the products but
you don't you don't sense the
you have no awareness of the mechanics
of it right
it's going on all the time um
and so one thing that's going on all the
time that you're completely unaware of
is that um when your brain your brain is
basically
asking itself figuratively speaking not
literally right like
how is the scent given the last time i
was in this sensory array with this
stuff going on in my body and i
and that this chain of events which just
occurred
what did i do next what did i feel next
what did i see next and so
it doesn't come up with one answer it
comes up with a distribution of it
possible answers
and then there has to be some selection
process and so you have
a network in your brain a sub-network in
your brain
a population of neurons that helps to
choose
it's not i'm not talking about a
homunculus in your brain or anything
silly like that um this is not
the soul it's not the center of yourself
or anything like that but
there is um
uh a set of neurons that weighs
the probabilities uh um um and and helps
to select
uh or narrow the field okay and that
that network is working all the time
it's actually called the control network
the executive control network or you can
call it a fronto parietal
because the regions of the brain that
make it up or in the frontal lobe and
the parietal lobe
there are also parts that belong to the
subcortical parts of your brain it
doesn't really matter the point is that
that there is this network and it is
working all the time
whether or not you feel in control
whether or not you feel like you're
expending effort doesn't really matter
it's on all the time
except when you sleep when you sleep
it's it's a little bit relaxed
and so think about what's happening when
you sleep when you sleep
the extra the external world recedes the
sense data
from so basically your model becomes
a little bit the tethers from the world
are loosened
and this network which is
involved in you know maybe weeding out
unrealistic things
is a little bit quiet so use
your dreams are really your internal
model that's
unconstrained by
the immediate world except so you can do
things that you can't do
in real life in your dreams right you
can fly like i for example when i fly on
my back in a dream i'm much faster than
when i fly on my front
don't ask me why i don't know when
you're laying and you're back in your
dream no
when i'm in my dream and flying in a
dream
i am much faster flyer in the air very
often
not often but you talk about it like you
i don't think i've flown for many years
well you must try it i've
flown i've fallen that's scary yeah but
you fl
you're talking about like yeah i fly my
dreams
and i'm way faster right and you're
better on my back way faster
um now you can say well you know you
never flew in your life right it's
conceptual combination i mean i've flown
in an airplane
and i've seen birds fly and i've watched
movies of people flying and i know
superman probably flies i don't know if
he flies faster on his back but
he's voice he's out of never see he's
lying on his front right but
yeah but anyways my point is that you
know all of this stuff
really um all these experiences really
become part of your internal model
the thing is that when you're asleep
your internal mole is still being
constrained by your body
your your brain is always attached to
your body it's always
receiving sense data from your body
you're mostly never aware of it
uh unless you run up the stairs uh or or
you know
uh maybe you um are ill in some way
but you're mostly not aware of it which
is a really good thing because if you
were
you know you'd never pay attention to
anything outside your own skin ever
again
like right now you seem like you're
sitting there very calmly but you have a
virtual whole thing drama right it's
like a
like a like an opera going on inside
your body
and so i think that one of the things
that happens when people um take
psilocybin
or take uh you know ketamine for example
is that the tethers
completely are completely removed yeah
yeah that's fascinating and then and
that's why it's helpful to have a guide
right because the guide is giving you
sense data
to steer that internal model so that it
doesn't go completely
off the rails yeah another so again that
wiring to
the other brain that's the guide is at
least
a tiny little tether exactly yeah
you